Hi, I'm Briana with freeCodeCamp
and today we're going to be talking about the
Binary Numeral System,
also known as a bunch of 1's and 0's
over and over again.
We're going to start by labeling, starting backwards,
how many numbers there are.
This will be zero, one, two, three, four, five, six.
Pretty straightforward so far.
The next step that we're going to do is:
Take two to the power of whatever place it is.
So here, it'll be two to the power of zero,
two to the power of one,
two to the power of two,
two to the power of three,
you get the picture.
Alright, now that we've got the two to the given power
figured out all we got to do is
fill in some lengths and we'll have our solution.
Two to the power of zero is one.
Two to the power of one is two.
Two to the power of two is four.
We've got 8, 16, 32, 64.
And that just keeps going on and on.
Next what we're going to do is see which ones of
these numbers do we keep.
So the next step: figure out which numbers do we keep.
Do we just add all of these together?
And if these were all ones, then yes we would.
But some of them are zeros.
The zero is the same thing as an off switch.
1 being on, 0 being off.
So we can go ahead and cross all of these out right here
because they're they're not going to really matter.
We want to keep this one, this one here, and here
because they have the corresponding 1's
which means: Yes! It's on!
We want to keep that number.
Basically from here on out. We're just going to add these
four numbers together. [Adding] Giving us, we've got 72, 74, 75.
So this number in binary means 75.